if your Honda keyi battery is dead I'm
going to show you how to unlock your car
and how to start it there is a link in
the description below where you can
purchase the battery for this specific
fob online also there's another link
that'll take you to a video that will
show you how to install the battery all
right let me show you how this is done
on that fob there's a little slider
right there slide it down hold the
oldfashioned key up now you're looking
pretty good cuz you're going to take it
and you're going to put it right in that
car door turn it clockwise and voila the
door opens if you want to lock the car
it's just the opposite put it back in
turn it counterclockwise and the car
locks now how do you start that car well
I'm going to put the fob right there on
the old steering wheel going to push the
brake and then push the start button and
this is what I get right on the screen
there it says to start hold remote near
start
button okay so I'm going to grab the
fob I'm going to put it right by the
start button and it makes a little
sound then I'm going to push my foot on
the brake press the start
button and there you go you're ready to
drive if you found this video helpful
I'd appreciate a thumbs up and subscribe
to fix and play where you can find more
videos just like this one have a great
[Music]
day